frankly
thank you
you know I was told sort of girly in the
protest like
creative stuff and if I had out of the
policing
I just walked away and with the guys
have a good
together how this
but they got the scraped it together we
got to move
right there call me but the most of the
world
I parties me
from all countries in the world like an
Argentine an extra cities were
work
I think sternal I didn't want to make an
overtly political movie um so I'm proud
that we didn't have some I don't think
it suits our sensibilities but I agree
with you I think obviously the politic
is in there and I think we just want to
show this this family in this situation
and it completely normal way and in that
sense of political because it kind of
shows how ridiculous it is that you
don't have those civil rights in this
country what is your net next project
and don't bring ya
we transfer our licensing the little
details universal I'm here at seven make
noodles we teach you guys anything about
pitcher Merritt are they
I think that
movies are nice analogy
to marriage against mature room together
you have to keep making a commitment
over and over and again and it's a
decision you have to
I think it really sort of taught us that
there are no shortcuts
get sloppy enough enough
character
uh yeah I mean you know it was some
a character in a film
sure
well it's a place I can opener and I
knew
well
Stewart get back and forth for a long
time we thought about shooting in New
York at one point that we ended up back
here and I think it you know there's a
sort of an elephant dance on a breezy
ness that we want to capture you know
this kind of flamenco family trying to
keep itself together against the
backdrop of the doors are always open
sound of luck Shanti and prosecute easy
you know gardeners are always fertile
kind of things so lambda temptations but
from it from an alternate view you know
not the typical Beverly Hills 90210
west side right here and let the rest up
manage your first day
that's gonna say cold but I don't feel I
feel cold yeah this is great because i
feel very satified getting getting here
getting the film all the way that we've
taken it the bigoted team behind it and
we worked our butts off and it's just
wonderful
it's have a wiping thank you
right here